hello and welcome to video playing my
way no way yeah we got this one okay I
didn't know that he places I'm
experiment a little bit with c4 at the
moment let's see what we get here we
have the boat Vinick set up here with e
4 let's see night to d4 yeah yeah that
gets played quite often in those
structures maybe I should have played 95
before think that's probably a little
bit more precise or anyway it's not not
a bad position
maybe he's aiming for f4 here you might
be able to do that if he takes both
nights then f1 hmm that's a bit awkward
bit awkward takes now and then F for ya
okay I'm not sure how bad it is but look
slightly annoying okay here interesting
a chick with the poor now Bishop g4 is
probably happening anything else taking
with the with the night is uncomfortable
I don't like to take with the bishop
much but maybe I don't have a big choice
um okay well after pawn takes d4 I have
Bishop takes you for that's actually
interesting now we'll see
hmm I wonder can you take on d3 well I
mean he can and queen takes the three
point XD for night XD form but that
looks quite okay for white so a bit
surprised that his i'm taking time here
and I was thinking night f4 is
interesting probably the IES rook takes
f4 is the thing and I can also do that
the problem here is a little bit that
yes these bishops bishops are generally
fine you know that I like my bishops but
it's not so easy here to get to my king
position without some nights I'm pretty
well defended him and even just go F for
soonish like f for King g1 91-93 this
will be a good regrouping in ok so mmm
doesn't want to take I guess ok i also
don't mind that much maybe it's Gettys
got g5 but i have Queen d2 as well as a
reply
now next move our Queen d2 look f1 I
wonder have some c6 as an IDF maybe for
him but okay I don't have to take my
idiotic seasick takes d5 this kind of
idea which I don't ever have to take 166
and tricky position yeah my water in the
opening was probably not quite quite the
best but it still feels like a playable
position here and with this one okay
not a move that I expected but it's it's
not bad ok so he might want to check on
e4 in some cases for example I had King
edge 1 as a possible idea then he is
very likely just going to take might
have Bishop f5 also a my night only to
win this is just not very good hmm I
know beforehand don't quite like this
night to d2 to see for this would be
nice but it's like this is the slowest
idea ever
don't like this
you
yeah i was thinking to goon i'd be three
of it he's got c4
I cannot take Nana let's see one was bad
I mean I am actually kind of expected
Bishop f5 but I didn't really look deep
but what kind of reply I might remind
might have wow just a very bad position
here
ng5 is just hanging I'm just losing
using a very simple fashion here I could
have taken it Vince okay does it have to
can also do that now check pretty bad f5
is going to time morning player g-form
and now if you takes Knight takes I can
get the five maybe I can fight a little
bit in check kc4 is still just around
the corner
yeah okay I cannot cannot go back and
would be right right right away silly
check yeah I don't really know what went
wrong here to be honest I mean it did
have a great position but I don't quite
understand when when it got to be so bad
this is at least kind of interesting
with the oh I can take no one d5 as well
check check
brah our third and probably still lost
here right or is there something wrong
haha probably I'm still lost yeah I'm
still lost Wow now that wasn't that
wasn't a good game at all I think I
screwed up the move order here we should
be three it's not a good idea here I
think 95 immediately it's a lot better
it belongs there anyway but now it's
something like this is just not a good
idea because I can take things like that
would be be losing actually just that I
want to take a night that comes to g4
and I couldn't do that in the indie game
that was a little bit annoying and here
this is this is not looking looking too
great yeah I can take with the porn but
if I thought that this would be it would
be more interesting yeah but he played
as well see 5 is a strong move that's a
strong move now I know I'm just worse
and I've I don't really know what to do
maybe I can regroup like this but he
still he has he has this year long term
and I cannot do much about it it just
just isn't great yeah now the engine
wants to do this I wonder what it wants
to do after this then I can take on a 5
takes you for mmm how it's just a
totally bad position yeah and I think
the way you played it was a fine i mean
it is probably winning here there might
have been something more more conclusive
but it's probably always winning this is
definitely winning that
oh here i have a draw with f6 and if six
was exactly the way it was implied but I
shouldn't take it seems check this and
back okay yeah okay that makes some
sense i'm also threatening this now that
would even win so jen jen wants to do
this and this is a drawing according to
the comp check check probably there is
no way forward and the engine gives to
give 000 probably correctly him and he
I'm losing a shame i just had to had to
play muslim oh yeah so this was a pretty
bad opening result i am didn't didn't
see that correctly this kind of position
well i think i always already bit
awkward to have this move and not being
able to take it but it's not not that
bad but probably around here i can take
with the poem maybe this is just better
i mean i saw that i'm attacking this but
i felt it's difficult to take and
there's always queen f6 and so on but
this is not the point it's probably just
a far safer option then this bishop
moves which is what's more more
ambitious but definitely not good okay
well thanks for watching